great my name is Greg hey reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm deysi Howard Stacy
Howard do you mention this in the other
video we filmed your uh movie fights
together guys who kicked my bu TT well
don't spoil it but I sure I serve today
oh man well you kick my ass or never
first to turn the Schmo down but you do
better than me every time that's right
so we're gonna watch this video day from
an awesome channel called a looper 2019
movies everyone will be talking about
before we do that I wanted to mentions
is not a product placement video people
get upset when you know you do one of
those but on the Stardust app John and I
have been posting a ton over there
30-second reactions for shows movies
trailers and sometimes we make like
little 30-second sketches over there
it's a lot of fun and yeah we just want
more people to be following us there
because we love posting on it and yeah
they're not sponsoring this video they
should but they're not either way follow
us a lot of big people are over there
and the other thing is - yes you are
fighting about for all you Star Trek
fans out there we are screening Star
Trek to the Wrath of Khan at the Malta
Bond theatre so that's Ricardo Montalban
Khan himself theater that he started
we're showing it on their roof which is
I mean Star Trek under the stars so it's
gonna be amazing it's October 5th doors
open at 6:30 so you can have some cool
themed drink some Romulan ale take some
cool photos win prizes if you get some
trivia right and then the film starts at
8:00 we're also gonna have q and A's and
meet and greets with different
influencers that are friends of mine
like you guys know some of these people
uh Scott mance Dan well mark and OPIC
Robert Myer Burnett John Roca Jason
Inman Ashley Robinson you guys are gonna
be there most likely all the best people
the people I will know I will come for
sure sure Arena screen comm I hope
everyone can make it it's really special
and just an event for fans absolutely
well I'll for sure be there now let's
get to it
headphones Stacy I kind of deserve it at
this point 2018 has been a huge year for
blockbusters for three months two
runners grocery a billion bucks of the
worldwide box office very mr. 19 is
shaping up to be just as massive with
more gigantic movies on the way there's
more Star Wars more Avengers and even
more evil demon clowns but that's just
scratching the surface here are the most
hotly anticipated movies of 2019 huh
hell boy oh boy another guy who didn't
make losses new tape and Hellboy On
January 9 with the stranger things start
joining director Neil Marshall for a
grittier take on the horn half-human
finally should expect that darker tone
than Guillermo del Toro's take on
Hellboy fighting giant p.m. on sort of
the big gun was taken Hellboy looks
spot-on the rest of the cast doesn't
disappoint either including Mila
Jovovich as a villainous blood Queen and
I know she's homeboys adopted father
I really have some experience with
[Music]
jumped in Marvel yeah it will be long
overdue when it hits theaters on March a
rather play major is shaping up to be
worth the wait Captain Marvel has
Academy Award winner brie Larson it's
Carol Danvers the Bible promises should
be as powerful a character as they've
ever put it all together Shore
that means she's strong how strong is
she so strong in the planet there's also
some impressive talent behind the scenes
[Music]
and even inside it's all lending a hand
to bring Captain Marvel to life
spider-man far from home some Holland's
continued as apprentice in a second
standalone film out July fair spider-man
homecoming was super successful with
both critics and fans oh yeah and the
follow-up is a massing of Marvel's
winning formula director John Waters
back to helm the web-slinger's next to
the most of homecomings excellent cast
to make a return we don't know much
about the plot so far from home but we
do know spider-man will face off against
Mysterio they've been and played by Jake
Gyllenhaal speaking of which Avengers
for the force commands is gonna be all
Marvel movies you should get your
tissues ready with many of the contracts
for Marvel's biggest names expiring
Avengers 4 will probably feature at
least a few major character Avengers for
terminus time if the studio continues as
a no-holds-barred approach established
in infinity war Avengers for sure to be
both completely epic and ridiculously
devastating ending several storylines
set up in past films while also getting
things from Anthony John wick three
Parabellum following the bloodbath of
the last movie wick is on the run with
her million dollar global contract on
his head lots of familiar faces are set
to return along with new additions like
very very installment to the
action-packed insane assassin franchise
features are saying director team so if
you love all things wick expect more of
the same to come back the third time
around hey why is the dungeon cage
[Music]
supervise kids known as the losers Club
as they dealt with 27 years later they
returned to Derry to deal with their
Senator Charles Johnson flounders after
the first films must have success it was
easy to land big-name stars to play the
adult loser shame Jessica Chastain James
McAvoy and Bill Hader they all make it
out alive
Wonder Woman 1984 while the woman is the
DCE used best performing film to date in
the u.s. so it makes sense that Warner
Brothers quickly ordered a sequel
auditor just Wonder Woman 1984 November
1984 found a way to bring back crisp
lines beloved Steve Trevor the film and
she's no stranger to begin to take over
the force awakens JJ Abrams is returning
to rightly directed trilogy finale
throughout December 28th episode 9 s
plot is still a mystery but all the
expect they're going to play my
self-esteem to return I really
well although major players but we care
before Betty Williams reprising his role
as fan favorite Lando Calrissian the
late Carrie Fisher will also appear
appear a news footage from the force
awakens Joker yeah Balian else world
style joke origin movie starring the
brilliantly weird Joaquin Phoenix is now
officially a real reaching scheduled to
start by the end of 2018 mr. J is going
to be co-written and directed by the
hangovers Todd Phillips with the Clown
Prince of Crime expected to hit theaters
on October 4 2019 Warner Brothers
describes the script as a gritty
character study but also a broader
cautionary tale sounds like it's no
laughing matter
Wow there's some movies to talk about
here yeah sure is let's go through them
okay okay huh boy the remake this is
gonna be a lot darker the makeup artist
is his stepfather to a really close
friend of mine and I was sitting down
with him he was telling me about like
how this one's gonna be a lot darker
it's probably gonna be a hard arse what
they're going for which I'm very much
excited for and he was showing me like
photos it released the still of it but
there were details to the makeup that
you just couldn't make out in the photo
that was released like little things
just like hair you know like have some
guys it's not like Oh it'll write them
here here or something yeah little
patches yeah and maybe show me those
details like wow it's so realistic
looking looks awesome that's cool out of
all the movies I'm gonna say that's my
number one really this one dissipated
yeah Hellboy and how was he the Golden
Army are two of my favorite comics okay
those I think I was like 14 15 and I
remember me and my brother going to see
that in theaters and he was a big hell
boy heel boy heel boy a fan and I didn't
know anything about you know the graphic
novels and so he was like sis we need to
go watch this together and I want to
introduce you to this world and I was
completely sucked in I just felt that
movie so much and I thought it was
gorgeous
so I have a lot of those films so to see
this I'm like okay we're going there
we're going to new people new look new
arms gonna be a lot darker and
everything more grounded gritty yeah the
other hell boys are very guillermo del
toro and then this one is I think they
want to honor the comic books a lot
closer
spider-man far from home but I love
about these announcements tomorrow
anytime you announce any of these Marvel
characters who've lost in the snap it's
confirming that they're not before he
would have been yeah I doubt it
what what I'm most excited for I think
what a lot of people are excited for I
can't wait for these set photos is Jake
Gyllenhaal is Mysterio we did a whole
video on it and Jake Gyllenhaal is
easily one of the most underrated actors
I think around today
Clemmy might be like wait time is
underrated I totally think he is this
guy gets shipped every year for an Oscar
nomination
he's never nominated and he never wins
you know this is heartbreaking and he
wasn't nominated for a Nightcrawler
which [ __ ] exactly which is like it's
arguably a very iconic role and I think
the Marvel villain problem has gone down
significantly in the past couple years
but I think man you say Jake Gyllenhaal
is a villain I'm like that's the main
thing I'm gonna tune in for yeah I know
I'm wondering if it'll be comedic though
because spider-man has so much comedy
and Mysterio is kind of a little bit of
a goofy character in some ways he can be
menacing but also kind of goofy try
swinging your way
[Music]
[Applause]
and I'm wondering if Jake Gyllenhaal's
acting chops will adjust to that style
you know what I'm curious about is why
Jake Gyllenhaal chose to be in this
comfort movie specifically because he's
revealed in interviews like he's been
offered to be a comic book
you know superhero dozens of times
Judy's come to him everyone has come to
him wanting him because he's like a
gorgeous buff guy a great actor they've
always wanted him to be this and so then
he's like no I don't be a hero I want to
be a villain and I'm gonna be a
spider-man villain it's such an
interesting choice well I think similar
cuz Joaquin Phoenix used to get offered
for comic book characters too but you
know it takes on the Joker I think for
actors such as those guys they're much
more drawn to the complexity of what a
villain can offer and you're not locked
in like I'm sure you sign some deal
where you might have to do multiple
films but you're also not locked in to
the degree that a leading hero is so you
have a little bit more leeway on doing
other projects and venturing out like
Josh Brolin's Ben Thanos forever I mean
not very beginning but I like I
appreciate that you tried hiding the
yawn I don't think he was danos then but
for sure when guardians of the galaxy
was around he was Thanos so even though
he had been contractually obligated to
make these appearances he wasn't like
committing months and months on end but
he could still do the complexity when
infinity war comes out and I think the
similar thing occurs with Jake
Gyllenhaal as Mysterio is there's a lot
more layers you can explore with a
villain like guardians all the villains
that have come out with Marvel I think
that Jake Gyllenhaal joining it is what
excited me the most it's really just in
terms of just casting like you're
casting you're like he's one of the best
right easily Avengers for you know I've
talked about it so many times with this
channel what I love about what's going
on with Avengers is it's been such a
long ass time that I can recall when a
movie ends it has such an amazing
cliffhanger and people just keep
speculating about what the hell are the
net what what exactly will
go down because I think what was
surprising about infinity war was how it
wasn't surprising but also so surprising
wait no but they're gonna show how
they're going back in time to do no no
so Avengers four people are still having
conversations about it and honestly I've
talked about it so much and I have
nothing new to offer here John wait
Chapter three
you know I don't love John wick chapter
two anywhere near as much as I love like
if I put on John wick one I'm gonna
watch John wick two it's just the way my
life is yeah put it on and I like it I
really enjoy it but I really feel like
there was a missing element with John
wick too which was the real personal
vibe and some people love that because
John wick one you know it takes a while
before there's an action scene and then
it slowly introduces it and then the
style keeps building and it gets crazier
whereas John wick - just starts off with
just like crazy action scene and it's
just like non-stop rock and roll action
yeah and I'm hoping this third one will
go back to having a lot more of that
personal gritty isolated darker tones
and cinematography as well that's really
the only ingredient looking for words I
know they're gonna deliver on the action
stuff this headshot of him on the horse
[Music]
that's amazing oh there we go there's
bill bill hader the fact that they got
all these people to play the older
version of these kids like every single
one of them was like perfect Jessica
Chastain without a doubt was the most
obvious but the most demanded I think
like they may not would you say older
you're like yeah and they got her she's
perfect like but not a doubt she's gonna
kill it Bill Hader is Ritchie I'm very
excited for because I think if you
follow Bill Hader you know he can do
great with drama if you follow him but I
don't think the masses are aware of how
good of a dramatic actor Bill Hader is
and Ritchie is supposed to be a funny
guy
you know and when he's an adult
especially he's supposed to still be a
funny guy but for it he's gonna need to
bring a layer of drama as well and I'm
really excited for that James McAvoy's
bill like I don't know there's a word
for you know how there's like the scream
queens for girls I don't know if there's
a word for guys but I feel like James
McAvoy is breaking into that territory
with things like split and now it yeah
this is one of those opportunities where
you can really go somewhere totally
different with a story in a sequel you
don't have as much room in a lot of
other films but this is like no whole
new cast whole new story like you can do
whatever you want I mean this is like
the dream this is like a dream lineup
like fantasy football draft it was like
oh my favorite players yay
it's more exciting than the mini series
of how they handled it BC the mini
series I did I was [ __ ] I hated the
adult form the adult portion was it's so
awkward kids work kids are a part is
great then you get the adult do is talk
about being kids I don't like any of
these people
chemistry and what I've heard about the
book too I haven't read the book but a
lot of people who have generally tell me
that the kids stuff is the better part
of the book too and that there are some
really weird stuff that goes on in the
adult we got to get that for the adults
so it feels ok I feel like for this one
they're gonna have to take a lot more
creative Liberty just knowing the
general response to how people talk
about the part of the book with the
adults I feel like this one the half is
sirak later a lot more of and do a lot
more freedom with that Wonder Woman 1984
were you saying about the um so her
headband
it's like 80s looking now the way that
they put it in her hair ah because
originally it was like right here and
then her hair flowed in like you know
1914 whenever time the war was and then
in the eighties one it's like in her
hair a little more and it's like teased
and like her ear it's like that it looks
more 80s the way they used to wear their
headbands you
nailed this yeah I didn't pick up my
like eighties fashion oh look at like
80s headbands they would put it like
when they're exercising and stuff ah do
that and then do that
I hope this Chris Pine thing is not real
and that it's just some figment of her
imagination because I think ruin do I
think you'll ruin the effect of Chris
Pine was around and why is he still
around and looking all right yeah after
like 40 something years you know it has
to be some just like dream thing where
she's imagining him it's okay I love
it's a figment of her imagination she's
imagining him in an 80s outfit Kristen
Wiig I don't know I think she's playing
a crow named cheetah I don't really know
much about that character I'm hoping
it's not a distracting thing it's kind
of a gamble of her performance I love
and she has done some dramatic things
like you look at skeleton twins and a
bunch of her yes like some indeed
totally totally things that she's done
but as a movie watcher I cannot get out
of my own oh it's Kristen Wiig from SNL
she's about to do a choice with baby
hands even when she's doing a good
romantic chop I'm still aware like
Kristen Wiig is doing good at the
Toronto Star Wars Episode nine you know
I feel like no one's really talking
about like putting this at the top of
their most anticipated arguably I
haven't put I haven't arguably stirring
like a sophisticated YouTube news guy
this is Collider videos here today
this is real this is like heavy [ __ ]
weird ugh Star Wars Episode nine I don't
think I've put the other Star Wars
movies at number one on my most
anticipated but this is not because I am
one of the people who does love the last
Jedi not even because I want to see the
follow-up to the last Jedi I'm so
curious how Lucasfilm and Disney is
gonna handle this
after the amount of mixed reaction the
last Jedi and not mixed just flat-out
divisive because all that level of hate
and the fact they're bringing JJ Abrams
back I'm like are they gonna play this
extra safe work it's kind of
disappointing are they gonna take any
Gamble's I'm not even really thinking
about what the plot is gonna be or
what's gonna unfold I'm just curious how
safe they're gonna play it or if they're
still gonna take risks and Gamble's you
know I really do want them to shape
risks and Gamble's because the only
reason they wouldn't want to take a risk
is if it's not gonna make money yeah
Juno's do not give a [ __ ] what fans
think about a film they care if they go
out and see their money to see a film so
the last Jedi made money they don't care
about like the mixed reaction they care
about yeah and I don't solo didn't
perform well at the box office my
argument for that is that it's because I
was trying to hold your hand there sir
my argument for that was because it was
so soon after the last Jedi and there
was such a wait that movie carried but
yeah I still think it's guaranteed to
make much I feel like even the people
who hate the last Jedi are like hate
this one and to see more of his little
like teen angsty drama going on and then
him and Rey having kind of like a
romantic connection of some kind yeah I
love that aspect of it yeah so I want to
see where that story totally and Billy
Dee Williams is coming back and if they
fall in the tradition of all the other
characters he's gonna be super sad him
depressed
it's gonna be make all the fans happy oh
man well this is fun list we just
started moving news channel yeah yeah we
should call it colliding junkies
colliders jump jump colliders well we're
gonna can that idea you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification well again notify one
one of our vids is up and you could
check us out on patreon TV show
reactions q and A's Stacey o Howard is
on social media but mainly she is here
to talk about that event that we plug
the top of this video if you made it to
the end link in the description box I
will be they're not going to Horror
Nights but instead watching Star Trek to
the Wrath of Khan and watching people I
have met many times before talk about
Star Trek to who the traffic on
afterwards yeah